this is the german-occupied town of see
where some are inside the crumbling
ruins is the intelligence you're looking
for you have to get inside and a sniper
like you always has plenty of options to
the east lies a Ridgeline where they're
empty aircraft guns are keeping our
Spitfires at bay it wouldn't mean
crossing the road in broad daylight but
above it lies a prime sniper nest it's a
tempting target the Germans Carling the
gate will probably be complacent and
doubt anyone will take them head-on
if anyone can call their bluff it's you
but the approach is fraught with danger
if you're feeling adventurous
intelligence suggests there's a hidden
entrance somewhere to the west finding
it could drop you right under the town
but there's an armored patrol between
you and your objectives it's time to
make your choice
sniper click one strategy on screen head
east to flank the patrols that we wary
of the officer above you he's got keener
vision than the grunts so you need to
take him out before he alerts his troops
to your location
if you wait to time your shot with our
Spitfire attacks it'll mask the sound of
your rifle from the rest of the troops
so you can approach the ridge undetected
then all you need to do is use your wits
and your silenced World War pistol to
clean up the aaaa Gunners and head for
the sniper nest getting into seewer is
just the beginning you've got to find
the Intel somewhere in the twisting
streets but don't forget your secondary
objectives either keep to the shadows
look for higher ground and cover your
retreat with traps only go loud when you
need to and make every shot count
one bullet can change history good luck
now try a different approach there are a
lot of soldiers patrolling this oasis it
won't be easy to get through but you can
use the environment to your advantage
tag the patrols to keep an eye on them
keep to the long grass get the jump on
enemies and keep bodies out of sight at
some stage you'll need to clear a path
to the gate sabotage nearby equipment by
the sound of your shots and use this to
get closer to your objective if the
Germans get suspicious booby trap a
couple of bodies and use the commotion
to sneak in undetected getting into
seewer is just the beginning you've got
to find the Intel somewhere in the
twisting streets but don't forget your
secondary objectives either keep to the
shadows look for higher ground and cover
your retreat with traps only go loud
when you need to and make every shot
count
bullet can change history good luck now
try a different approach the Germans
have the Oasis on lockdown but they
can't cover every inch of the
battlefield use the terrain to outflank
them you don't want to be spotted close
to the city if you need to kill make
sure they're isolated and be as quiet as
possible the choke point could be tricky
but you can tip the odds in your favor
by using your flint and tinder with some
TNT to set up a nasty chain reaction if
you're quick you can use the chaos to go
loud and clear your path to the entrance
getting into seewer is just the
beginning you've got to find the Intel
somewhere in the twisting streets but
don't forget your secondary objectives
either keep to the shadows look for
higher ground and cover your retreat
with traps only go loud when you need to
and make every shot count one bullet can
change history good luck now try a
different approach